joy reid is one of the hosts over at the
televised mental institution
known as msnbc and really listen to what
she says here really listen to what she
says and let's see if you can get to my
conclusion i'm pretty sure you can good
evening everyone we begin the readout
tonight with republicans just tying
themselves into pretzels
to point the figure in every single
thing but the problem the gun
in the wake of the murders of 19 fourth
graders and two of their teachers in
uvalde texas
from mental health to arming teachers to
more armed law enforcement in schools
every single thing
as far as we know there was no mental
health issue with the individual who
stole the futures of 19 children in
uvalde texas
that line right there you got it already
i know you got it you guys are good if
you're watching the show that line might
be the stupidest thing that has ever
been said
on msnbc and that is an incredible
statement to make and i think it might
be the idea
that a young 18 year old kid
walks into a school
murders 19 4th graders and some teachers
there's no evidence he has a mental
health problem it's about the gun
that is so
absolutely effing bananas that that
someone at ms she should have been fired
on the spot if msnbc was a news
organization and they're not it's a
clown show ridiculous progressive
propaganda network
she should have been fired immediately
that statement is so
insane
it's so reverse and then she said well
they all they want to talk they don't
want to talk about the gun the gun's
obviously the problem they only want to
talk about mental health and this had
nothing to do with mental health
everyone in this watching this you all
know 18 year olds you all know 17 year
olds and 19 year olds okay
none of them that you know most likely
would do anything like this this kid had
a massive mental problem
it's off the charts what his mental
problem was okay we may never know
exactly what it was but why doesn't she
want to talk about mental health why
doesn't she want to talk about security
at the school why doesn't she want to
talk all all about the cultural nonsense
that is unearthing this because they're
the ones peddling all of this so on one
hand you've got chuck schumer saying ah
you see the republicans and those mega
conservatives and blah blah there's
never enough blood for them and in
essence they're excusing the shooter he
obviously had no
capacity over in his own mind there was
just a gun there so he decided to kill a
lot of people
complete insanity complete insanity and
they're doing exactly what they accuse
all of us
of doing